thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an
enlightening wild ride with Stevo
anybody who is a regular listener of
this podcast knows how big of a deal
this episode is it is the author of the
books that I Rave about constantly
called conversations with God and I call
Neil Donald Walsh my life coach because
from his books I have developed my
understanding of life and the universe
I'm telling you this is my favorite
guest I was dying to get them so ah get
ready and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen my life coach Neil
Donald Walsh I uh have spoken so often
about how much your books conversation
with god have have helped me the most
traumatic thing that ever
um I went through my mom suffered an
aneurysm
and she survived it
but she came out
the heinously physically and mentally
disabled and and she had bed sores I
developed a real anger towards God and
by changing my perspective to that all
of a sudden
God didn't allow that to happen to my
mom there's no separation there that
that was God forgot my mom is God and so
that um
that that helped a lot it really really
did it's still you know I would Echo
what you said I don't understand it I
you know I don't uh
I don't I don't like it but I think I
view view it more as
um
natural law of cause and effect like if
uh
you know that that my mom my mom had
alcoholism she smoked for many many
years and I can understand
that the you know consequences yeah let
me ask you a question
do you believe do you believe in the
existence of the human soul yes
do you believe in the existence of this
entity or this Essence that we call God
yes
Stephen what in your
awareness is this the relationship
between the soul and God
they are one and the same
that
um
I mean God
and the absolute is is pure love it's
one thing but being only one thing it
cannot have experience so
God in the absolute divides itself into
you know many different things which
creates the realm of the relative so but
all things are God so let me ask you a
question can
God as you understand God to be
be victimized in any way that is can
anything happen to God that God does not
want to have happen no
if the soul is one with God can anything
happen to the soul that the soul does
not want to have happen can the Soul be
victimized in any way no
then why would your mother's soul
choose to experience what she
experienced the last five years of her
life
um
that's a tough one it I don't know I
know but if you thought you knew what
would your answer be
if I thought I knew
um
I mean it feels like a stretch but
but the
the journey that I went on from from
being so traumatized by everything that
happened
and then the shift in the perspective
and I mean I I don't know there's
there's something
the there's there's something about my
journey and oh
working through that and and and
overcoming it
that uh that I could see has value Steve
I think at the soul levels your mother
might have known that
her
situation and the condition in which she
found herself
would have
an impact and an effect on you that
would change your life for the better
I could I want you to consider the
possibility then
that your mother at the level of soul
was not unaware or ignorant of the fact
that I've just described and that her
last five years
she went through at a physical level
was her final Act of love for you
it's um
I'll take it it's a tough one but but
I'll take it
it doesn't have anything to do with like
Soul contracts it's precisely
I mean that's her acting out her
contract knowing that
what I'm going to move through now
will bring enormous
benefit ultimately
to my son
and will open him to an awareness
of so many different things that he
would not have been opened to if he
hadn't
been visited by that kind of emotional
emotionally traumatic experience in life
so what kind of an emotional trauma from
my parents could really open
my son
to an awareness that I already hold at a
spiritual level
see I think that your mom graduated
from her own misbehaviors
at a spiritual level her soul knows you
know that is not really the way to go
that's not the way to make the best use
of this physical life
I wonder how I could
say that
to my son that he would really get it
because if I just said it verbally
don't don't don't do what I did and so
forth you're probably not yeah okay Mom
and and then blow it off
but what if I found some way
in fact what if we agreed ahead of time
Soul contract
that we would have this opportunity for
me to send that message to him in a way
that would be so
searingly present he couldn't possibly
ignore it
huh
so
I'm I'm going to suggest
that when I was told by
God in my conversation is there's no
such thing as a coincidence
that nothing happens without us
understanding reason the part of
all the if I could put it this way all
the players in the game all the actors
in the scene
then you could almost
some level
release any
lingering sadness
you have
about what your mom went through and see
it as her
Act of Courage bravery
and her final Act of love for you
and by the way if your mom was sitting
between us right now she'd be seeing
Neil you nailed it
yeah she probably says something to the
effect of like
that's what it took to get through his
his fat thick stupid headers she was
always YouTube me too buddy yeah shake
hands on that me too right it took me 55
years of my life to get through my sick
skull what was really going on here who
I really am what the purpose of this
whole thing is
I mean I blew off half A Century Of My
Life
not knowing
yeah I think a lot of people do that and
I think I think you can
you can make great progress to figuring
out who you are and what it's all about
and then you can just lose it you can
it's uh it's glimpses that we see it in
and then those glimpses just fade into
I think I do that a lot I think I kind
of get
to it and I feel like really plugged in
and then I lose it
I do want to ask about
Soul contracts now
not from conversations with God but from
other
sources I've I've seen about
um
have
the the sole contract it's it's a a
blueprint for life and and kind of
choosing what experiences we want to
have in our body in order to
work something out have some experience
and and uh evolve in a certain way and
in
in putting together this this old
contract this this blueprint for for a
life uh at that point we're not in a
body we're we're
I suppose in between lives where where a
spiritual entity you know and as that
spiritual entity I've heard that we will
choose our parents
we'll choose it we'll choose our parents
um we will
um
make an outline for events that are uh
predetermined which are going to shape
the experience that we're going to have
in in our life
and uh and then when we when they when
the agreement is is made
uh part of the agreement is that as we
enter the body as we incarnate as as a
human
that we forget the whole deal
and then we're kind of
because if we knew the deal it wouldn't
invalidate the experience
but my question is
how does the idea of a blueprint of a
life contract with
uh
things predetermined built into it how
does that reconcile with free will how
does that yeah how does that
jive with free will yeah I wanted to ask
this question so badly for the longest
time and I might add that I believe
strongly if there is a blueprint for my
life then it involved figuring out the
difference between wiping my butt and
washing my butt because it is a big
difference are you still using dry
toilet paper to just smear poop all over
your butthole I mean come on you're out
of your mind you've got to get hip to
the butt washing program from
hellotushy.com
this is revolutionary it has changed my
life man I love blasting my butthole
with the refreshing stream of water from
my bidet from hello Hershey I'm telling
you man it cuts down on your use of
toilet paper by 80 percent and as such
the thing pays for itself in no time it
also doesn't require any special extra
Plumbing or any special electricity you
just attach it to your toilet and you're
good to go plus if you go to
hellotushy.com
Stevo then you get 10 off your first
order I've raved about this company
since the beginning of this podcast and
I have always said they are my favorite
sponsor of this podcast it is
hellotushy.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo for
10 off your first order now let's get
back to it
you said a number of things there that I
wanted to interrupt you
with
or on when you said them but I wanted to
give you the chance to
make your mistake I
[Laughter]
love it
huh first of all
knowing that you made some comment of
knowing ahead of time what's going to
happen
you said that one of the last things you
said would so we have to we have to
forget we have to agree to enter into
temporary Amnesia otherwise if we knew
ahead of time what was going to happen
it would invalidate the whole experience
Stevo having appeared in
probably 36 or 39 in separate stage
Productions on stage as an actor I mean
I've also directed many shows but I've
had a rich background in Live Theater
I can't tell you that that isn't true
I've done dramatic rules in which of
course I knew ahead of time what was
going to happen in the next moment in
the next scene because we've rehearsed
it for three weeks and I knew exactly
what the next scene was going to be what
the lines were going to be
that didn't stop me from feeding the
emotions and feeding them deeply
as if it was happening to me for the
first time
and all and not that I am a great actor
but all really great actors would tell
you that that's been exactly their
experience
they cry real tears
not make-believe tears
when they moved through a particular
scene that they've done
for for five years on Broadway
but they still have the emotional
response
because the mind cannot stop itself
if it's truly engaged in the moment
from responding
in the way that love
would call forth even if they know
that what's going on is play acting in a
sense
you wouldn't know what it cost me to
have those people out there doing that
at the right time well yeah I I I I've
paid
I paid them a lot of money
[Laughter]
let me tell them this that
so I'm not all together convinced that
knowing ahead of time
would stop us or prohibit us from having
a an emotional response a genuine one
I I and I again I've I've encountered
moments in in stage plays in which I've
appeared
uh where I knew what was coming and even
knowing what was coming
triggered the emotional response that
what occurred in the play was it uh
designed to trigger
so um that's that's so that's one thing
I just wanted to say is that I'm not
sure that we have to not know in order
to have a genuine emotional response and
have the experience that we came here to
experience but now
let me go back to something before that
that you said that I also am not sure
that I totally agree with
I don't think that there's a blueprint
I don't think that that we have a
contract that says you know on a certain
day at a certain time you're going to
sit uh down with a man named Stevo
and have a conversation
in which you make him terribly wrong for
three and a half minutes
and he laughs at it
I don't think that this experience was
agreed upon by us nor do I think the
major events of my life were agreed upon
in terms of the events themselves
okay so my understanding because
um I asked God the same question wait a
minute How can there be a contract How
can there be an agreement and also be
free will it they don't they don't they
seem to be juxtaposed
so and God said ah good question
the uh understanding that I have Stevo
is that
[Music]
um
events are not planned ahead of time
we don't have predestination and Free
Will are mutually exclusive
but what the souls do agree with is to
create certain emotional emotionally
filled
opportunities
but how that will play out in terms of a
specific event
is is not designed ahead of time so to
to
use the present example of your mother's
last five years of her life as an
example
she might have it in fact I don't think
she might have I think there's no
question that she made an agreement with
your soul you realize made an agreement
how about if I provide you with an
opportunity
emotionally to Grapple with
deep personal sadness maybe even at some
level emotional injury
um
such that it would transform and change
your life and bring you to a new
understanding that you are going to go
into your next lifetime in order to have
you you could have had that contract
yeah I'll sign here I let's do that so
we agree on the emotional content
that we're going to seek to create for
each other but we don't agree on oh it's
going to happen on the 14th of July at 2
30 in the afternoon and I'm going to be
having bed source for five years right
and this is how it's going to look
because that would make Free Will
impossible
so my understanding is
that
we agree on the emotional content but we
don't
you know we're like we're like players
out in Orchestra Stevo my the the
analogy that God gave me was
there's a 67-piece Orchestra and by the
way I've conducted orchestras so I know
all about it what this feels like
they're all playing Mozart but one guy's
playing a flute one lady's playing a
violin one fellas playing the Tiffany
and one man is on a saxophone they're
playing the same music but in different
ways using different instruments so I
think that this whole contract is in
agreement on what music will play
now that you know the score
you understand what I'm saying
right is that a play on words you love
or what I love it
[Music]
so so we're all playing we're all
playing Mozart put here on the violin
you're on the cello I'm on the Tiffany
you know and and we're playing it the
way we are playing it
and in that way Free Will is
memorialized Free Will is protected if
you will continues to be part of our
experience
we freely choose to enter into
particular interactions on the physical
level
as the way we have decided we're going
to
keep our agreement in terms of providing
emotional content for each other to grow
with okay I think that there is a
potential wrinkle here when
we talk about
other players in the Universal game
joining us
and
does that uh
that can you help me understand what
happens when when another player in the
game becomes involved in my life
hmm
I think it's important for us to
understand that everything that's ever
happened is happening now and ever will
happen has already occurred right so
what another person joins it in the
interaction in some way or another
um they're also doing so I'm not sure
where the wrinkle is because they're
also doing so as an expression of their
free will that is they have a choice to
do that or not to do that
by the way
both things have occurred
see it's very important for us to
understand what's going on here
both let's just say
your co-host's name again is Scott Scott
so let's just say that now Scott is
sitting there
and he's interacting with all of us but
but he could he it was also a moment
when we did this interview when Scott
was not here at all
if I just never even met Scott it wasn't
even part of your life
both things have happened right and and
so what I was told in conversation I
know this sounds like I'm making it up
as I go along but really this is really
important because I was asked I asked
these same kinds of questions in my
dialogue was gone
she said Neil it's really very simple
you think there's only one timeline
but there are a hundred different
timelines
in which everything has occurred and I
said I'm having a hard time
conceptualizing I can hear the words but
I can't I can't quite get that in my
mind
and God said okay
have you ever played chess with a
computer
I said sure I played computer chess God
said you do understand of course and all
the moves have already been made
every single move in the game has been
made so you play the game on Thursday
and you move you know King's King's Pawn
to King's Pawn 4 or whatever and and
then the uh and then the computer goes
that makes its move and you make your
move and it makes its move how does it
know what move to America because it's
already you've already made that which
already happened but but on Friday you
play the same game and you make a
different move
so you you can play the computer your
chess game and you have to understand
that all the moves that are possible
with all the players on the board at any
given moment have already occurred
the game's been played already a
thousand times that's how they
programmed the game because computer
chess experts sat down and said well
okay but supposing you didn't move your
knight there suppose he moved over here
and they they took months programming
the the game so that no matter how you
play it the computer has an answer I sat
there I played computer chess scada I
mean Steve Moscato Stevo whatever
I was I was played the gaming on the
computer would make its move and I would
go I'd spend like two and a half three
minutes trying to figure out let's see
now if I move the Rook here no wait wait
wait I'll move
I don't know if I did that he's going to
do it oh you know like you play chess so
I figured out all the moves I thought
okay I'll move over here it took me
three and a half minutes to make that
move the computer sees the move it goes
makes its moving one tenth of a second
so wait a minute don't you have to even
think about it
it's already happened I said
this is not a new thing for me
right so so the answer to your question
is I as I understand it Stevo is that
when a person comes into your life
they're also exercising Free Will and
there have been many lifetimes many
times through The Time Tunnel when that
person did not come in at that at that
moment into your life
um I I wasn't thinking as much of people
I was thinking and
that in my reading of the book I'll
highlight certain things
and uh I was going through it
um
and there was uh it said
players with a capital P in the
Universal game Universal game and
they'll come into your uh commentary
life and I didn't interpret that as
people
but like more
you know
spiritual entities I suppose
I think that's a fair interpretation
my mind is telling me that that also
could be true yeah we are visited by
spiritual entities Angels what are your
guardian angel whatever you want to call
it
uh
uh I by the way I've had those
experiences as well
yeah and the reason why I ask that is
because
I feel somewhat strongly that there were
times
in my life where
to for lack of a better way to describe
it
um I I want to say there were times when
I wasn't at the wheel
like
I um
I I did something that
makes no sense to me like why did I do
that and um I felt that it was important
that that this thing happened but
looking back on it I just don't see I
don't understand
why it happened I don't understand why I
did it and I feel like I feel like I
wasn't at the wheel maybe there was some
other player in the Universal game that
kind of stepped in and and somehow
manipulated
uh what happened for a desired outcome
now I reserve the right to be totally
wrong about that but I've won I wanted
to put that to you about like what are
your thoughts about if there ever being
a time when I wasn't at the wheel
because another spiritual entity
manipulated what happened with me
I disagree
with that particular description because
that would also violate Free Will right
that makes sense and so
another entity could not cause you to
not be at the wheel okay but here's what
I do think happens in moments like that
because I've had those moments too
when it felt like I wasn't at the wheel
excuse me
and it felt like I wasn't at the wheel
not because I wasn't at the wheel
but because I didn't know that I was
right and I didn't know that I was
because
I was at the wheel to use the metaphor
driving the vehicle of my life from a
different level of consciousness
I'm aware that we're functioning in
every moment of our life at the
subconscious at the conscious at the
super conscious and at the Supra
conscious level
and when we're responding from the Supra
conscious level or even the super
conscious level we also often do things
that we are not consciously aware of why
we're doing that what would cause me to
do that why would I like you just like
you describe why why would I do that
um so I think that those moments are
moments when we are functioning at the
super or Supra conscious level
at a level that our conscious mind is
not aware of but that does not mean that
the totality of who we are right at all
four levels is not at the wheel it just
means that we're not aware aware that we
are at the wheel right it's kind of like
you know when you're sleeping
and you're not aware that you're awake
but you are awake and you still think
you're dreaming
most of us have had that experience only
to realize
I didn't dream myself I didn't dream I
heard that sound
I actually heard that sound I'm
I got it my God you may have been awake
all this while and most of us have had
that experience of realizing that we're
awake but not knowing that we were awake
while we were awake until we awaken to
the fact that we're awake
it's important to know if you're awake
and it's also really nice to know how
well you slept last night how much time
was spent in REM sleep let me see right
here I had
32.7 of my time asleep last night was in
REM sleep that might indicate my body is
making up for not getting enough REM
sleep recently how do I know that
because I wear a whoop band and if you
listen to this podcast then you know a
lot of really awesome people wear root
bands why because it's the most
sophisticated Fitness tracking device
known to man plus now it tells you how
oxygenated your blood is if there's
anything unusual about your skin
temperature I mean dude it knows like if
I'm skateboarding like I did yesterday
it keeps track of all the calories I'm
burning how well I'm recovering I'm just
I love my whoop band and I love the
whoop app and if you go to whoop.com
that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use the promo code
Stevo you can get 10 off your membership
and I'm telling you with the new whoop
4.0 band and the waterproof charger man
it's never been more awesome to wear a
root band so jump on this deal it's ten
percent off your your first order and it
is at whoop.com with the promo code
Stevo now let's get back to it
I'm thinking potentially an equally
valid
um interpretation you gotta love it
right yeah I mean you gotta love the
mystery you gotta love them you gotta
love the mystery excuse me but oh no
it's great I mean so our highly evolved
beans operating at the Supra conscious
level or is it just a different ball
game at that
I think I think both are true I'm not
just suggesting that a highly evolved
beings are interfering see how the
evolved beings would never interfere
with our life that's another reason why
they couldn't do right what uh what
you're suggesting Stevo because Ohio
being would never want to have anything
to do with your life that would control
the moment for you right and take your
hands off the wheel that would violate
the ethics of a highly evolved being
it's no no no no no I'm not doing that
right I'll give him advice I'll maybe
give me a little but I'm not going to
take the wheel from him and then make
him think that that he you know that he
lost lost control of the car
so so highly of our beings would never
do such a thing in my understanding
right I think that that's that's very
fair to say and I think an equally valid
interpretation would be that when I
thought like what I
thought might have been another player
stepping in and and manipulating my
experience
uh was actually me right like that other
player was me
so that's that's what I've been trying
to say except you put it in 10 seconds
words 10 words and I put it into 150
words darn it
at least it was something that you just
said to you about the that would violate
the ethics and I think it wouldn't just
violate the ethics of Highly evolved
beings but it would violate the
immutable laws of the universe of course
Star Trek
what was the prime directive
I can't well the prime directive was you
know you were not to not to interfere in
any way in the cultural or sociological
or Spiritual Development of another
civilization even though you saw it was
would see it was for their own good
not to interfere that that's the whole
that's the whole point of the prime
directive
there was
a a period of my life where I was
experiencing what's called psychosis
because I was ingesting
it's just the all of these substances
uh you know I would be awake for
days on end you know doing cocaine and
and inhaling with inhalants and all
these combinations of sleep deprivation
and and you know acute
uh you know intoxication from the
substances would bring about psychosis
and my take on that
still to this day I had you know
approaching 15 years of chemical
sobriety
is that that's going by the way thank
you
um
I I genuinely believe that by ingesting
all of those substances I managed to
erode
barriers
between uh maybe other dimensions other
decision in other situations I I hold in
my belief that all of the experiences
that I had with hearing voices with
having a
tactile hallucinations all these
experiences that I had
were very very real
and that by eroding the barriers of
different compartments of the game that
I I
let in
I I consider it frequencies but but I
let in you know other energies other
frequencies of high frequencies low
frequencies so I opened myself up to
pretty dangerous stuff you know like the
like high frequencies being Angels low
frequencies being demons and and I had
all this some experiences really scary
and some really wonderful and it's just
it was I view it as a really crude
approach to spiritual experience
um and uh
in these
hallucinations the hearing the voices
there was the I called it the committee
you know and I would be kind of
communicating with these this Committee
of uh and and I remember the committee
being very very clear on that rule that
their hands are off they're not gonna
interfere with anything
but I just wonder what your thoughts are
on that on psychosis and because at the
time I just wanted to keep in piling
more substance and you know to keep
these things happening I had some really
wild experiences and that's the danger
of it
the danger of it
is that
it becomes attractive enough at that
level
for us to want to continue
now I I really can't answer your
question directly you know what do I
think of it because I've never had an
experience even close to that
so I don't really have an opinion and I
didn't ask in my conversations with God
questions around that so I've tried real
hard in my life not to opine
okay
by the way if you think it's easy to
work that word into a sentence try it
something you can go years without me
I've heard it done once in my life this
is the second and so so I tried to not
offer opinions on things
of which I have no experience no
background no understanding and I did
not ask
uh in my conversations with God but I
when I heard you talking about it just
now
my mind was going
hope
that there's not going to be too
attractive a picture painted here
that would cause a person to say well
help that's I could see that as a
rationale a good reason to ingest some
things that maybe yeah not be good for
me to ingest or to imbibe or to
so we could we could maybe send the
wrong
um I I appreciate that I appreciate that
and um there is a uh a wealth of
evidence video evidence like
um where I was was not an attractive
place I I can assure that my my life was
an absolute disaster and I was a very
unlovely creature I I became at that
time capable of of being very
nasty
um you know I I think it's a spiritual
law that the way we treat others is a
reflection of how we feel about
ourselves
and at that time in my life the my
self-esteem my self-worth my you know
everything about me was was degraded to
a point that the way I treated others I
I had Tendencies to to want to harm
people's reputations hurt their feelings
I just and and and all of that behavior
during that time
um brought about a level of of guilt and
shame and humiliation which ultimately
would become
the greatest motivation for me to
dedicate myself to a life of recovery to
not be that way again so I love that
you're sensitive to the idea that we
might be that I might be glorifying the
these spiritual experiences when in fact
inadvertently of course yeah but that
someone else could could hear that and
say you know it sounds fun right sounds
like at least interesting yeah give it a
try yeah I don't recommend inviting
demons
into your life that that's really what
what it was
um can I
just wrap my head around some things and
maybe you can help me if I'm saying this
right and have an understanding
all things are energy right yes that's
my understanding so Consciousness well
plants trees people we all vibrate at a
certain frequency
people vibrate
within a a frequency spectrum a spectrum
the lower the vibration
you know I heard Wayne Dyer talk about
this but I'm not sure how accurate and
how to even test how fast the frequency
levels are but he's something along the
lines of you know from 8 000 to 25 000
is like you know the average human
population or whatever speed that
frequency is then you start getting into
the realm of like you know thirty
thousand to fifty thousand and disease
doesn't really exist at that frequency
and then you get you know 60 to 80 is
you know Gandhi Buddha Mother Teresa
where now you walk like
you know at a lower frequency but at a
higher level like you walk into a party
and there's just something about that
person in the room and you're like man
you're kind of attracted to that person
then as you get higher in the frequency
like Mother Teresa or
um people come from villages to go flock
to see this person like the attraction
is there and everybody wants to go see
this person and then as you get to like
you know the highest highest frequency
is like Jesus Christ or you know the the
mahavatars of the world am I spot on to
think that or am I off in some sense
you don't know
I didn't ask that question
but I think that
my mind
feels that there's
some truth I'm not sure that the
description is wholly completely and one
thousand percent accurate but I think
it's close
to what could be true I don't I don't
think there's any doubt that people are
and every living thing
as you mentioned every living thing is
vibrating at a different frequency
and I don't think there's any doubt as
well that the higher the frequency is at
which they're vibrating
the more they tend to
display
demonstrate
Express
what those high frequencies
have made clear to them what what they
have come to understand about who they
are and why they're here
and I don't think there's any doubt at
all that those high frequencies tend to
be magnetic that we do in fact tend to
be attracted to people like that I knew
a man like that by the way on a personal
level
that I that I appeared with at several
events in the past 20 years we didn't
co-present but he was appearing at the
same event I was appearing at
his name was tignan Han and he was a
Buddhist monk he said celebrated his
continuation day
but I I was at several events with
tiknot Han and I and I I promise you
that and we had speakers we always had
speakers dinners or speakers receptions
where the general public was not there
just the presenters were there so there
were only maybe 10 or 12 15 of us as
opposed to 1500
I'm in a room with you know like 10 12
15 other people and taking on Han walks
into the room
I promise you
that without even looking at the doorway
looking maybe talking to somebody else
everybody in that room knew that
something incredible that just happened
and he walked in the room he didn't say
a word when he first walked in we all
knew that he was there it was it was his
his energetic impacted and affected the
entire room
because of the frequency of that he was
bringing with him that he was projecting
I wonder when you describe people coming
from other Villages and the more uh the
higher the level of the frequency the
more the magnetism
I can't help but react to that thinking
that there's some pretty low
vibrating people attract you know
since the negativity almost attracts
more like the if you look at the media I
like what you're saying that's a very
good Insight when when uh Scott was
talking about the higher frequency I
didn't hear him say the better
all right I only say the higher
right the higher the yeah well those
lower frequency people or that come to
the like you like the lower frequency
goes to the higher and then they're
leaving there on a different frequency
themselves I think it's well I think the
point that Steve was making and I'm
going to agree with him is that even
so-called negative frequencies or what
we would what were kind of like
intuitively wanting to call lower
frequencies
but what we really mean are more
negative for instance you know one of
the highest frequencies that one can
project into the universe is fear
and no one would suggest it fear is a
positive frequency we would call it a
negative a negative emotion yeah so so
uh likewise there are people who project
so-called by our definition by our
current human definition so-called
negative
energetics but those energetics are
vibrating very quickly they're very
powerful
fear is one of the most powerful
energetics that you could Embrace and
when you project fear into the universe
you attract what your conversation with
god told me that Neil you will attract
what you fear wow that's pretty heavy
you attract what you fear it's a good
thing I don't fear a bad diet because I
got ag1 from athletic greens baby the
most delicious comprehensive convenient
daily nutrition there is it plugs in
every Gap in my diet I'm telling you
because it's loaded with 75 different
vitamins minerals Whole Food sourced
superfoods probiotics adaptogens I'm
telling you they load so much good stuff
into this I don't have to be afraid of
anything about my diet plus it's great
for my gut health it's great for my
cognitive ability I mean dude it's
called athletic greens for a reason and
ag1 is the supplement of all supplements
with everything you need it is
comprehensive and convenient and if you
go to athletic greens.com
slash Stevo they will give you five
travel packs plus an entire year's
supply of immune boosting vitamin D with
your first order you can't beat it go to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo and let's get back to it
not because your frequency is so low but
because it's so powerful
that fear and love are almost equally
powerful in terms of the energetic
that's sent into the universe of course
fear is nothing more than an expression
of love
that is if you didn't love anything
you'd fear nothing if I didn't love my
life I wouldn't fear losing it if I
didn't love you I wouldn't fear losing
you if I didn't love money I would if
you're not having enough you know so
fear is always an expression of
something that you love it's simply the
other side of the coin it's just the
inverse expression but it's distance so
it has to carries the same
power to say energetic the same
frequency which is the point you made
and I agree with you completely yeah the
once again Steve is wrong and you're
right yeah exactly that's wrong all
right it's always that and now
um yeah that when the when the Law of
Attraction phase came out you know in
the early 2000s and and everybody was
there's that book that or that movie
that came out yeah maybe what the
bleeper I don't remember the secret and
which I was in by the way yeah and uh
the one thing that they some people were
talking about that got a wrong law of
attraction is there but what they didn't
touch upon was the law of resonance that
what you put out will come back to you
equally so when you're like okay you
know I don't have any money like okay
Law of Attraction like I want money like
where's my money it's gonna come back to
you at the same way whereas if you had a
like gratitude like I already have all
the money I need and then all of a
sudden that kind of starts showing up
back in your life in that sense you know
how I've conceived of that in my in my
world I agree with everything you've
just said
Scott
and how I was told that what I was told
in my life by God God said
I only have one word in my vocabulary
I know you think that I'm really verbose
that I have a lot of things to say but
the truth is I have only one word in my
vocabulary we love
yes oh right so if you say I want more
money in my life God says yes
that's true you do
I wanna I'm tired of living alone I want
my perfect partner in my life yes you do
yeah I'm afraid I'm afraid I might lose
all that I've gained in my work so hard
I'm afraid I'm going to lose it God said
yes you do
but if you say you know all the money I
need is coming to me now God equally
says yes that's true
so what I've what I've learned is that
when I get that God says yes there's
only one word in God's vocabulary
whatever I say whatever I think God says
yeah I agree with you you know why I
agree with you
because you are me
because I've invested in you all the
power to create your reality that I have
invested in myself that you are in fact
a living demonstration in individuation
of me so of course I'm going to say yes
to whatever you say because my friend
your wish is my command
the the
game-changing quote in your book that
changed my life about money was when you
were writing the God and um he responded
with
you know you're unhappy with your money
situation because you're unhappy with
your money situation and that was like
oh my God
that summed up everything for me
when the secret wouldn't you know I I I
read the The Law of Attraction book when
when I was in the early recovery I was
still in rehab
and
I wonder if you've heard of this I had a
very very
scary reaction to it I thought oh so
what I think will become my reality
and
then it occurred to me well you know
they say if you if you tell yourself
don't think of a pink elephant then all
of a sudden all you can think of is a
pink elephant so by the rules of the Law
of Attraction what if
I tell myself don't think my greatest
fears because then they'll become a
reality that's what it is the the what
you think becomes a reality oh no now
I'm telling myself don't think about my
biggest fears because then that one and
then oh no now all I can think about is
my greatest fears so now my greatest
fears are going to become my reality
[Laughter]
yeah
now we're in a Hall of Mirrors here
that's that's a very interesting and
wonderfully incisive uh description of
in fact some of the challenges we're all
facing here
it's like you know going into the fun
house at the carnival and all the
mirrors are warped and you know and
you're in the Hall of Mirrors
what you're setting out is reflected
back to you what you're sending out is
reflected back to you and if you don't
want to send it us reflected back to eat
a bit of it but you know that kind of
thing until you finally wake up on
things wait a minute
wait a minute
I can even
decline that effect
the whole thing is an illusion
wow the whole thing is an illusion
I'm living in a
the 10 illusions of humans
the whole thing is made up
I can even
describe that effects as beautifully as
stevely as you just did now and I can
say no
I don't have to I don't have to even
find myself seduced by that impact I can
just say I'm above all of that
when I did that I found most helpful
was to go back to the the notion that
the way we treat others is a reflection
of how we feel about ourselves I could
buy onto that because I I saw that that
was my experience
and
I decided that the best way
to change how I feel about myself it
would be to flip that to the same rule
would apply that if I can change the way
that I treat others the effect will be
I'll be changing the way I feel about
myself who's a guy who made that point a
few years ago he put it in a somewhat
different way but it was the exact same
point he said
do unto others
as you would have it done unto you
it's the Golden Rule he made the point
exactly the point you just made
sort of yeah that's sort of exactly okay
yeah I mean I I uh do unto others as you
would have it done unto you how much how
much more clear could it be you're
exactly right and by the way I just
admire that you came to that awareness
oh wow
how I treat others is a reflection of
how I feel about myself and I can change
how I feel about myself by treating
others the way I want to be treated
mm-hmm
whoa that's world changing Stevo
it's life-changing and world changing
supposing that everybody on the planet
got that piece of information tomorrow
morning at nine o'clock
everything would change
it's it's more um
about about uh seizing upon the
opportunity to feel like a guy who
treats people well
you know like uh
I I was talking to a friend who's um you
know having a relationship issues and
and I said you know that
with with my fiance
I have a
something I don't I don't always do it
well but when I do it I benefit from it
a lot
which is to view every
situation I'd find myself in in my
relationship as an opportunity for me to
express myself as the person who I
aspire to be
and it's a little way of taking
something that you know maybe it's a
pain in the butt but if it's an
opportunity for me to be a great guy
then yeah I'll I'll go to the to the vet
at two in the morning because you think
the dog might have eaten chocolate or it
probably didn't it's gonna be fine
anyway but
let's go
that's
chip changing insight
I hope that all of the many many many
people
who view your programs Stevo hear you
that's that's a relationship changing
Insight that's that's the the best thing
I've ever done for my relationship is
selfishly use it to feel good about
being a good guy
and to realize that
even when the person across the room
is not
behaving or responding or demonstrating
an aspect of themselves that you'd like
them to demonstrate even when they're
being you know cruel or short or snippy
or whatever or unreasonable two o'clock
in the morning the dog didn't have
chocolate I'm not going
you know even when they're being
unreasonable that we can say oh I see
the gift here
I see the gift
you love your next book
no really
that's the title of your next book
I see the gift
by Stevo all right
that's cool yeah and the the truth is is
probably these Reese's Pieces rapper and
he blamed it on the dog
because he's like you know what he's
just barking out the wrong tree can I
ask you a question about the uh the
conversations with God movie and how
accurate that was
um there's a scene there that I was
interested in
um you were homeless
you started to have you were sleeping on
the couch you were you started having
the dialogue with God and you hadn't had
any money for a while and then there was
a part I believe that the airport
you had uh you're at the or the the
diner at the cafe and they made you an
offer for four million dollars for for
the the transcripts and your the the in
the the show the lady turned it down and
you were like what are you doing
it it was that a real situation that
happened yes and what were you thinking
Russian a lady to turn it down uh I was
here my the guy turned into Tom it was
the lady who made the office yes sorry
she didn't turn it down she was in fact
uh the the president of
a major publishing company and my zen
publisher she was wanting to buy the
book from him
in future books and he turned it down
and I started to to I said well but this
is as far as I got because he's under
the table he's stepped on my foot he
slammed his foot his his shoe on the top
of my foot like shut up I'll handle this
but it wasn't it wasn't uh my memory of
it was it wasn't 4 million it was 8
million
and then and then he and or maybe it was
who knows but I think that she offered 8
million he looked at her and he said
well I can do that myself
I don't I don't need to I we can do that
on our own my Publishing Company the
small publishing company that first put
the book out
then she came back with an offer of 1.5
is my memory of it okay she came back
with an offer at one point which in
those days was worth about in today's
money more but in any event uh she came
back with it she with 50 more
and then and then I wouldn't let him
turn it down I just it's
but I asked her I said why why do you
want to why would you make an offer like
that what tell me what you see in this
and she said
I'll never forget her words by the way
she said
because I think your book could change
the world
[Music]
um
is it true that conversations with God
book one
can you hold that question of course we
didn't get to your did you had a
question behind that other than that
yeah I think I I mean it's like
assuming living in a tent in Oregon
and you have zero dollars in your bank
account I mean what are you sitting
there thinking when somebody offers you
a million dollars and the guy turns it
down I mean what's
the fear there is like it's never
happening like what were you thinking
when when they turned it down like were
you like oh my God what did they just do
I just made a mistake or yeah I started
to say well well he stepped on my foot
yeah so he didn't step on my foot you
slammed his shoe on my foot like you
know shut the hell up
I'll handle this with the unspoken yes
so so uh yeah but I did I did think at
first you know the guy's crazy you know
why why would he turn that down
and because I knew I would benefit
obviously as well
um
but
so yeah I I was pretty taken aback
before that when you had no money and
there was probably some resentment
towards God about I'm broke on this and
then you wrote you wrote it on the couch
and you know you heard the quotes you
know you'll be happy with your money
situation when you're finally happy with
your money situation from that did your
did your thought on money change I
thought I'd never seen change and it was
more of a gratitude and then from that
time when everything changed to where
you got that offer like you were
practicing the Gratitude of money's
coming my way or you know
yes but
that didn't stop me from you mentioned
about a half hour ago you're in it and
then you're out of it and you're in it
then you're out of it and yeah it was
one of those moments you know I was
living really in the messages I truly
was I felt like I was pretty much in
that bubble in that cocoon I had
received the messages and I was
practicing them and I was getting it and
I was you know
and then this and this lady offers a
million dollars he turns it down and I
popped out of that bubble like that you
know wait a minute this transcends my
current understanding
[Music]
so so I did and and that's still my
experience
you know that's still my experience that
certain things happen
certain things occur and I burst out of
the place that I'm in I burst out of the
bubble if you please I I find myself
knowing what I know
but not being able to
Express or experience it in that moment
now I'll give myself this much and
without
breaking my arm patting myself on the
back I do it less now than I did before
so I've I've reduced the number of
moments like that
but I still have times when I think like
you talked about you know
who is that masked man
who's that guy who just did that who
just said that or just responded in that
way when you know better
so I don't think
I was gonna say I was almost tempted to
say I don't think the game ever ends
but I think that it does
I'm going to withdraw that thought
because I I have met people like
technology or Byron Katie
and other people I've met in my life who
have reached a level
[Music]
um
where they don't fall fall out they
don't fall out of a space they don't
reject what they already know they don't
abandon themselves
but I so I abandoned myself less now
than I than I did 25 years ago I'll give
myself that as I said yeah
but uh I'm not really still
where I want to be and I'd like to you
know I'd like to get to their I'd like
to get closer and closer and closer
before I check out of here I'm going to
be 80 next year wow I'd like to uh that
was your cue to say you don't even look
close to 80.
that's what I meant by wow
do you still meditate every day except
on days that you don't no yeah I never
did meditate every day
I do I don't but that explains why
you're so far more advanced
he's glowing over there I don't know
about that
um but you know let me retract that I
said I don't I mean I don't meditate
every day the way people describe
meditation
because they think it has to look a
certain way but I write every day every
day of my life I'm writing something
into the message and around the message
and around my life and so forth so my my
form of meditation really is to is to
write and I write hours not a few
minutes here and there
from 7 30 in the morning until four in
the afternoon I met my keyboard either
answering questions from readers or
writing another article for that's been
asked of me for a magazine or writing
for my website I have a column called
ask Neil where people at you so so I'm
constantly so that's my my form of
meditation people can meditate doing the
dishes right people can meditate walking
down the street
and I I talk about seven methods of
meditation so when I say I don't
meditate every day I mean not the way
people think you're supposed to
meditate but I meditate in my way and I
sometimes meditate while I'm washing the
dishes
and I experienced a glass in my hand and
the soap bubbles on that glass and the
water dripping down in a way that I
never did before I see it sometimes for
the first time
so meditation doesn't mean a particular
action
it's a particular mental function that
allows you to focus
in a totally different way
on what's going on in your life
including focusing on nothing mm-hmm
I have a quick question and then I
wanted to
get you to
okay quick question do you still hold
the world record for being on the New
York Times bestseller list longer than
any other book with conversations with
God book one
I don't know
I understand it was almost three years
like I believe it was 140 131 weeks 37
weeks I think 137 weeks I don't know by
the way that's not not any non-fiction
we need to say nonsense oh gotcha
because fiction books I've been on the
best set on this for you know five eight
ten years in a long time but non-fiction
books typically do not remain on the
best seller list for that long got it
um but I I don't I don't know I I don't
track that out well I just I love it
because I think that
that when I describe conversations with
God I say that you know it's this this
book that fundamentally changed the way
I view life in the universe that it um
it's a dialogue I described that you
were at a place in your life you felt
frustrated and that you had been in the
habit of writing letters which you
wouldn't necessarily send but it was an
exercise inventing that you would you
know write a letter to someone and maybe
just file it away
but you were at such a point of Despair
my father taught me that by the way yeah
it's a good practice I was angry he'd
say write a letter and put it on the
mantle piece look at look at it tomorrow
if you still feel tomorrow after you
read it you want to send it then send it
yeah the 24-hour rule yeah
yeah and so at this certain point you
weren't experiencing such disparity you
decide I'm going to write a letter to
God and you know
why is my life such a struggle why is it
you know everything like that and that
you intuitively received a response
which was are you really looking for
answers to these questions or are you
just venting
and um you know it's for a lot of people
it's a difficult pill to swallow that
that you're able to write both sides of
the dialogue yours and gods
and to the extent that that's a
difficult pill for some people to
swallow
we look at how long it was on the New
York Times bestseller list which adds
some credibility your lens some
some weight to it you know and for me I
said it's not necessarily for everybody
but for me it is absolutely my like it
to me it's the most important thing
um what I'm interested in because I
don't think it's been made clear
um can you describe how the the
intuitive responses come I think there
is some suggestion that like uh you felt
your hand moving or like was there yeah
I don't want to make uh the case for
automatic writing I I did feel my hand
moving but not in the sense that people
think of automatic writing or someone
else is kind of like taking their body
in his writing more in the sense of if
you've ever owed your mom a letter
and you start writing and and you and
your your hand is moving without you
you're really thinking seriously about
dear Mom I'm really sorry I've let it go
this far you know please forgive me I
I've been very busy and you find
yourself you find your hand moving
without you really consciously thinking
of what I want to write and then and
then after you get all that out of the
way then you start actually writing the
truth is why I'm sending you this notice
I need 200 okay can you help me out here
or whatever you know whatever the the
real reason is so so in that sense but
but not in the sense of automatic
writing yeah how it how it occurred to
me how it felt to me was
I heard
a voice and it was in when I very first
heard it in the very first moment I
would have sworn someone was in the room
with me
and I whipped whipped around there was
nobody behind me I Heard a Voice that
felt like it was over my right shoulder
and of course there was no one there and
I thought
terrific
not only am I Furious not on my angry
with life angry with God now I'm going
out of my mind I'm hearing
hearing voices you know all about that
so then I thought terrific
but then
the I no longer I dismissed the idea
that that I you know that I'm actually
hearing voices out loud
but then I began to just receive
thoughts just
you know just heard
ideas words in my head
in response to what I was what I was
writing
do you really want answers to all these
questions or are you just venting I
remember writing furiously in answered
to the to what I was being asked
yeah I am venting if you've got answers
I'd sure as hell had to know what they
are
yeah and the response I got immediately
was wouldn't you rather be sure is
heaven
I said what's that supposed to mean and
I realized I was caught up in the
two-way
I didn't even try to describe it I just
went with it
and then before I knew it
I was involved in a question answer
question answer a question answered
process
never stopped to ask myself about what's
going on here why is this happening who
what is it I just let myself and then I
began receiving
thoughts that never either never
occurred to me before
or that violated every thought I ever
did the whole wow
you're like there's no such thing as
right and wrong
or there are no victims and no villains
in the world
well there's no such thing as the Ten
Commandments that was the one stop you I
remember dropping the pen
when I was given there's no such thing
as the Ten Commandments I literally
dropped the pen like like it was red hot
I thought
what is this what's going on here what
did you describe is it's not Ten
Commandments it's ten suggestions or
it's not Ten Commandments it's ten
commitments okay 10 commitments
and and what she said was
you will know because because you know I
I asked the question when Moses came
down from the Mountaintop he said he had
been given you know this tablet with Ten
Commandments and he's talking to his
people about how they should then behave
and uh what I was told was no no no no
no no God didn't say these are
Commandments these are things you must
do or else right but you've asked how
you how can I tell my people that
they're not that they will know
that they're on the path
and you'll know what you you'll know
you're under I'll make this commitment
to you you will know you're on the path
because when you're on the path
you shall not
use the name of
God in vain
you won't lie
shall not lie
you you won't commit adultery you won't
do these things because when you're on
the path you simply won't do those
things and Moses heard it is you won't
do those things meaning you you better
not
and so he kind of flipped it around
right you know and so but but I wrote
the rewrote the Ten Commandments as the
Ten commitments as I was given into
dialogue
you know Stevo I got a letter about oh
about a year later a year after that I
guess after the book came up
from a minister a
Christian minister in New Hampshire I
think
and he said Dear Mr Walsh I can't tell I
lead a congregation you know the first
whatever Church whatever in
he said I can't say that I agree with
your theology but I will say this much
you have opened the discussion about God
in a way that few people have done
in my lifetime and my congregation is
talking about nothing else but what
you've said so you have you have broken
down the barrier of the Beast because in
most churches you can't even talk about
this stuff you can't I mean you can't
question it right and of course there
are countries where if you question it
puts you to death yeah they sent the
sentence you to death because you're not
supposed to question what the scripture
says what you've been taught
so I thought well it's the worst that
I've done is opened the subject for
re-expiration
fair enough
fair enough and I want to make I want to
make something really clear Stevo if I
can
since you've been kind enough to give me
the floor here
I need people to understand that I know
I didn't write this book
the wisdom the insights
the statements
the truths that are offered in all nine
of the conversations with the god
dialogue books
are not mine and did not come from me
simply took dictation
I simply wrote down what I was hearing
questioned it like anybody would like
you would like anybody else would
questioned it like how can that be true
wait a minute what about this yeah but I
had Bunches of yeah buts yeah but
so all I did was add my earbuds
and then I carefully took down
what I was given and I just took
dictation
and I sent it to the publisher I will
say this to the various publishers
nobody has ever edited my books
you know I've been asked that what did
the editors do when they get your books
none of the Publishers who have
published my books could find an editor
on the workroom floor
who wants to edit God
so so nobody no so the books have been
published exactly
the way they came off the pen for the
first three and off the keyboard for the
other for the other books nobody has
ever changed a single word in those
books
so for what it's worth I took dictation
and they published it and the rest is
they say
it's history
I love it I I would say we should end
there but I wanted to
uh there was one thing and I believe it
was in book two and I loved it so much
it was
a point about
there being no such thing as time and in
the dialogue God said
look at how ridiculous and I'm
paraphrasing but look at how ridiculous
your attempt at creating a construct of
time is in order to to make it work you
guys are trying so hard to make this
work that you've gotta not include a day
uh every four years to make it work
you're trying to just squeeze you know
you got your leap year and then like
with the meteor time like this is just
there's this infinitesimal fraction of a
of a you know of a second that just
doesn't quite fit so every so often you
gotta not have a second like it's
doesn't do you not see how ridiculous
this construct of times it's it's a
making it all up yeah I I loved that
yeah
and and all you have to do to realize
that there really is no such thing as
time is live to your 80.
the closer I get to my 80th birthday
which is now just you know a year away
or so less than a year where
the more I realize I woke up actually
this very morning thinking about when I
was 24 and when I was 14 and when I was
29 and 36 and it really does feel like
yesterday so
um yeah I'm clear that time does not
exist in the way that we think that it
does
there's only one moment and that's right
here right now
I had I wonder what you think of this
with regards to time
many years ago probably about 20 years
ago
I was sitting there on
I thought
it it used to be
a commonly held belief that the world
was flat that actually the sailors
were afraid to ride their ships too far
because they thought they would fall off
the end of the Earth
and
we've
evolved enough in our in our in our
science and our understanding that
that's become an absurd thought because
you can't fall off of the the end of the
Earth because the Earth is round
and then I asked my question when I
wonder when we may have evolved enough
to find it equally absurd that we can
fall off the end of time
hmm you know they we have this idea of
time as a linear thing with the
beginning and an end but if much the
same as the Earth is round we can't fall
off the end of the Earth it would follow
that time is round there's no beginning
or end
you don't fall off time is round dude
yeah which is which is uh Saturday in
conversations with God
take God said take that I know I
remember she gave me an illustration you
think time is a straight line that goes
it starts here and it ends here whatever
that is at the end of the world or
whatever you think
God said no no grab that line grab that
line and
marry it and you'll see that it's
everything is a circle
yeah and he said to me not just time but
everything everything is the circle not
only is it a circle everything is a
circle which is actually traveling in a
circle around a circle bingo
really fascinating that
in book one
it
you asked about is there any limit to
how small something can get or how big
can something can get and the answer
from God was that you can cut something
in half
you have two equal pieces then you can
take those pieces you can cut them in
half
and there is no point
like literally for Infinity
you can always cut something in half
there's no there's no end to how small
something can get and just and it goes
the other way as well
so
so conceivably in the space of an atom
is
all of the information
the history the future the possible
outcomes
can fit like
it
in an atom the smallest particle that we
can fathom smaller than an atom would be
an atom yeah I don't know whether we're
aware of anything smaller subatomic
particles there are subatomic particles
seven So within a subatomic particle we
can fit
the entire universe
yeah and what she said to me was if you
if you go to outer space and look at the
universe
you will see nothing different from if
you could stand far enough away from
your body and look at the particles of
your body
well the particles inside the particles
of your body it's all the same
Construction
so but you know the real the real the
question these are fascinating
observations that we've all become aware
of
at some level or another but the real
question is so what does that have to do
with life for instance if everything's a
circle you know there's an eel sitting
there and Stevo and Neil are agreeing
everything is a circle but if I'm
watching this podcast I gotta go
fascinating but
so what
what does it have to do with me at four
o'clock tomorrow afternoon I said talk
to me about stuff that matters to me and
produces functionality in my life
okay
and that's what we'll be doing on our
second interview because we're going way
over time here yeah but if we have
another hour and a half we could take a
look at you know what is the
functionality
because if if the message is from God or
messages that we're receiving from the
cosmos from the universe from the higher
evolved beings or whatever
or from the place of wisdom that dwells
within all of us
have no functional applicability
then it becomes a big so what
yeah and I'm not interested you know a
theology that has no applicability is
bankrupt
and I'm not interested in being
spiritually bankrupt
so what I've tried to do
in the books I've written that I
actually have written as opposed to the
books that I took dictation for
[Music]
um
what I've tried to do in the books that
I've written following the dialogue is
to
articulate the applicability
of these principles that were given to
us in the conversations with God
dialogues
how does that apply in relationship in
the world of business in the world of
work with regard to money with regard to
health with regard to how does that all
apply
and there's way too much there for us to
get into here but I can tell you that
nothing that we are given
in those words of wisdom that I took
dictation on
is not applicable in a functional
practical way in everyday life including
the idea that it's all a circle
yeah
I love it
I love it I love you Neil thank you for
uh let me tell you something I admire
about you before before you say goodbye
to me
I really admire the fact that you're so
honest
you're visible you're transparent
you don't try to hide behind anything
you're just completely honest and
transparent
and it's hard to find people who are
willing to go there
and do it fearlessly not just go there
but go there fearlessly so you when you
do that you're a demonstration to all
who watch your podcast
you're a wonderful demonstration and a
wonderful model and that's something
that I
admire about you I've seen your podcast
this is it's nice to be on it but I've
actually watched some clips of your
podcast I think wow disguise in the
moment totally present and he is
transparent he's hiding nothing he's
being totally visible that takes a level
of Courage
to say nothing but the courage it took
you to overcome your addictions so you
know what pal
nice going hey thank you so much Neil
you're right you're my favorite you're
right here you're my you're my favorite
teacher you're uh my favorite author
your my favorite thinker and I this
meant the world to me the check's in the
mail
did I tell you or what that was just a
big deal man and thank you guys for
sticking around candidly I I'm guessing
this isn't going to be the biggest uh
performer of an episode but it was just
important to me and for you guys making
it to the end of this one man that's
more special to me than ever so thank
you especially for this one and what
else can I tell you
um we're in Australia and it's been
challenging frankly the the tour bus
that we rented when it rains outside it
rains inside because there's just hella
hole in the roof but that stopped
mattering when the bus totally broke
down and uh yeah we were on the side of
the highway so I uh quite literally
hitchhiked to the show that night I mean
I got on the road hitchhiking like 10
minutes we had like eight different cars
and trucks pulled over like trying to
get photos and stuff so hitchhiking's
actually pretty easy for me in Australia
but yeah dude the bus stayed broke down
so we took six hour cab ride to the show
the day after that now I'm in this
traveling sauna of an RV the the air
conditioning doesn't work
man nothing I won't do to get to my
shows baby and thank you Australia for
making them such a hit with that thank
you again I love you all